[Music]
yo yo today we're going to be talking
about taking kids to funerals and how to
teach
kids how to grieve we're going to be
talking about
dating again after a divorce and we're
going to have a heartbreaking
conversation
with a wife and new mother whose husband
is addicted to video games
stay tuned
hey what's up i'm john and this is the
dr john dolone show
where we're taking your calls about your
life
we're talking about relationships
relational iq
how to get along with one another how to
fight fair your mental health
parenting we're gonna be talking about
maybe
folks who are still raising the roof and
folks who are still making don't scoop
lug day jokes
dude enough if here's the thing the roof
is as high as it needs to be
we're all good on that and if you're
still skipping leg day
you should probably go to church there's
something wrong with you okay so let's
all just agree we're done with
the raise the roof and the leg day jokes
but back to it we're gonna talk about
all that we're gonna talk about
everything
all right so whatever's going on your
heart your mind your universe
your planet your church whatever it is
i'm here to walk with you
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291 or email me at ask
john ramseysolutions.com that's ask
john ramseysolutions.com all right so i
want to start today before we go to the
phones
just before we went on air good friend
james here who's running
the sound and and is the producer of the
show he forwarded me
a podcast title
here's the name of the title how to
install our here's the name of the
podcast
how to install a successful operating
system
in your child and dude
i almost instantly got rocket diarrhea
and here's why i cannot stand
when people think of their kids as
robots or computers
and here's why if you think your kid is
a computer or you use
nonsense like i need to upgrade my kid
or i need to get him a new operating
system
i know you're trying like people are
trying to be cool and like talk with the
times
those type of metaphors are dangerous
because what happens is you look at your
nine-year-old and they do something that
nine-year-olds do they leave their
towels out
they talk back to somebody they
gallop into some wall somewhere because
their bodies are growing faster than
their brains are
and your default setting becomes there's
something wrong with my kid
or i need to fix something or there must
be a broken line of code
and that's why we've got so many parents
not totally wise some of the reasons why
parents will go sprinting to their
doctor or to the internets what's wrong
with my nine-year-old
nine-year-olds and twelve-year-olds and
twenty-year-olds and fifty-year-olds
are not robots or little boxes of wires
that need upgraded operating systems
everybody needs people who love them and
who will be with them and who will look
them in the
eye and acknowledge them listen to them
and value them and hold them accountable
and punish them when necessary and and
in but
stop with the install a successful
operating system in your child
just quit with the nonsense man how
about this how about
how to love your kid how to love and
hold
and hug how to instill value into your
child
let's make that podcast i'm gonna make
that podcast james we're gonna go with
that one all right so
let's go to the calls i just
rocket diarrhea before we even get going
all right let's go to lucas
in riverside california lucas what's up
brother how can i help
hey john thanks so much for taking my
call today um
i think you are a phenomenal addition to
the ramsey network
and love what you're doing so uh thanks
for talking to me today thanks brother i
appreciate that
so i am a funeral celebrant here in
southern california
and every now and then the topic of
having children at funerals comes up
people may have had a bad experience
growing up or they don't think funerals
are
quote appropriate for children and i'm
just wondering what advice or guidance
that you would give
to a family regarding having kids attend
funerals or even
be part of them in some way man you
stumbled into soapbox number two for me
and we haven't even gotten rolling lucas
so before man i've got all kinds of
thoughts on this before i get going
what do you think you you live in this
world you deal with
death you deal with grief you deal with
all kinds of spectrums of mourning
and frustration and denial what do you
think
so my my initial thoughts and
what i've kind of i guess haphazardly
counseled people on before okay hold on
hold on hold on i'm gonna stop you there
yeah so i'm gonna use you cause you
called okay
let's don't say kinda and you know
i want you to be speak boldly here's
what i've been doing this here's what i
recommend and and have the courage to be
wrong but i'm i'm almost guaranteed
you're not gonna be
go for it perfect i'll be confidently
wrong if i'm wrong
yeah lucas getting it so i tell people
that
our culture is incredibly deaf averse
and
most people don't have these
conversations and
i suggest that kids be involved as early
as possible because if kids
can love somebody they can experience
grief oh my gosh
dude i'm high fiving you from nashville
to southern california
i you are in the right job you are the
person that people need
when they're experiencing loss and their
experience experiencing brokenness
i one hundred thousand times a million
percent agree with you
we have stripped all
negative emotions we've pathologized
everything that doesn't feel
quote-unquote happy
right and we've labeled it as depression
or anxiety that's the two that we kick
off all the time but you're exactly
right we try to hide and shield
uncomfortable feelings especially from
our kids and you've got to pay the piper
on that one somewhere down the road
right
um so here's here's a couple of my
thoughts lucas and
weigh in because you're an expert here
and i'm i'm more of
a sideline quarterback i believe with
all of my heart
to take every kid to every funeral
particularly
when they are in their close fear
and meaning their their grandparents
their their
parents their siblings their cousins get
your kids involved
in funerals and celebrations of life
let them see you sad let them see you as
a parent
mourn you are not doing your kids any
favors by hiding it
i have a personal example of this one of
the things that
my dad did so my dad was a homicide
detective he dealt in
in the ugliest of the ugly he dealt with
death all day every day
as a part of his the first half of his
career
and one of the things he did for me was
he sheltered me from funerals
he didn't want me seeing the stuff that
he saw every day
and at the time that was wise and that
was good and he was doing the best he
could
and here i am 25 35 years later
and that cost me for a season i went
through a season where i didn't know how
to deal with
death i didn't know how to deal with
grief i didn't have the tools
and i didn't have a map i didn't have an
image of a mom
and a dad who were sad and still loved
each other
who had healthy coping mechanisms and
and
just how to live life through tragedy
and so it became an important thing for
me to make sure my kid was exposed to
not grotesque and gruesome things but to
go to funerals to um experience sadness
to see dad and mom sad and to say what's
wrong mom and dad to see tears come from
our eyes because that's part of the
human experience
i heard a quote man maybe about 15 years
ago when i wrote it down it was
kids are overexposed and
underexperienced
and i think that that attributes i mean
that's that's for all of us right
overexposed and underexperienced and
what that means is they've seen
a million dead people on a computer or
on tv or in a video game and they've
never been in a room
and felt the weight of someone who's
actually died a dead body there
the passing of a loved one the
collective grief
and that goes on right they've seen a
million sex acts on tv
they've seen a million sexualized images
and they've never
burned an entire movie just trying to
you know to move their hands in the
right way so they can hold hands with
somebody that they're you know that
they're in love with they skip all the
steps and so
they've got these images they've
downloaded the the images there we go
using a freaking computer analogy what a
[ __ ]
um so they absorb these images but they
don't have the
experience to back that up and you get
that disconnect in their brain and
you're just asking for all kinds of
trouble
so lucas it's it's been my experience
which again is limited compared to yours
that one of the greatest gifts you can
give a child
is to let them attend a funeral with you
let them attend a viewing with you let
them see people who are crying
let them experience what your body feels
like when you're sad
and to then process it with them to talk
about it with them
to show how you can value people when
they're not there
how memories remain with you right how
that impacts your
your spiritual walk it just impacts
everything so what what do you think
about that does that make sense to you
oh absolutely yeah that's that was that
was kind of i guess that's kind of i
guess i just
it was it's good to hear somebody affirm
that
because that's the one area i'm not
really that trained in and so i just
wanted to make sure i was on the right
track i guess
absolutely and lucas i would even go one
step further there's become a new trend
over the last five to ten years where
people would say i'm just too sad i
can't go to the funeral
ridiculous
go to the funeral i don't care if you
don't feel like it i don't care if you
are
sad and i'm talking to grown-ups here i
don't care if you're sad i don't care if
it's just
it just feels heavy you gotta go your
body
needs that collective processing it
needs to be in community with
other people who are grieving to help
you get through a process
if you skipped a funeral if you didn't
go to your dad's funeral because of x y
or z
i'm going to recommend that you hold
another ceremony
hold a special moment if your dad sucked
or your mom was abusive and you say i'm
not going to that funeral
i don't care who you are that winds its
way into your body into your collective
into collective your collective psyche
having some kind of process whether it's
writing them a letter
whether it is writing them three letters
i've recommended that before write a
letter for
thank you for what you gave me write a
letter for
thank you or screw you for being such a
terrible parent
and then write them another letter with
here's who i'm becoming and here's who
i'm gonna be
and whatever your process is have
a process we've got to stop
being so scared of feeling uncomfortable
of feeling sad and of feeling
lost right that's a part of the human
experience and we can't we can't skip it
one last thing i want to throw out there
and again thank you lucas for that call
one last thing i want to throw out there
if your kids feel grief on if kids feel
grief on their parents
meaning let's say somebody at church
passes away and mom and dad are sad
dad loses a friend like maybe not a
close friend but just like an extended
friend at work
and dad's sad but dad thinks you know
what i don't want to
bring my nonsense down on tim tim's only
six
and susie's only four i don't want to
bring my sadness on to them
the kids will feel that grief they will
feel that sadness they'll feel that
disconnection
and what small children especially will
do is they backfill that gap
with i must have done something wrong
i must be the reason dad is feeling this
way and you'll
it's you'll feel kids you'll see kids ex
like withdraw from parents who are
mourning
or get super clingy which is real
frustrating when you're trying to mourn
so i lost somebody that i love recently
my football coach that meant a whole lot
to me he died two nights ago
and i got the news on my phone and
my dad sent it to me and i got sad
his name was coach loper i loved him he
played an instrumental role in
my growing up this is a young
knucklehead little boy
and i got sad and it just so happened
that when i
felt that sadness josephine my
four-year-old came around the corner
onto the front porch and she said daddy
what's wrong
and i pulled up on my lap and i said
daddy's mentor daddy's friend died
he's no longer with us and she looked at
me and put her hand on my face and said
daddy that's sad i'm sorry
and she's four and she's already
understanding that
people pass away life is hard and that
sometimes the best thing you can do for
somebody
is to look them in the eye and say i'm
sorry and put your hand on your face
and for a four-year-old that means i
love you i love you i love you so all i
have to say is that's what i'm doing in
my own house
lucas good for you you're in the right
place we're blessed to have you all
right let's go to the phones let's go
back to the phones let's go to chelsea
in kansas city missouri
chelsea what's up hi john
how are you i am outstanding how about
you
i'm doing awesome good so how can i help
this morning
i have recently gone through a divorce
and getting back out into the dating
scene
and i just it's hard i'm in my mid-30s
and i just want some guidance on how to
make this
work and i have two kids two young kids
six and two
so six and two so how long were you
married
um that's interesting i was married for
a year then we divorced for a year
and i had my daughter was two at the
time and
i dated somebody and it just scared me
so much i remarried my ex-husband again
and we had another kid and then so you
were you remarried because you got
scared you remarried because you got
scared are you
remarried you dated somebody new and
thought no he's the one i love him
or i don't want to invest in any more
time than anybody else
what was the reason you went back it
wasn't cause you were scared why'd you
really go back and remarry him
well it was kind of out of fear because
i didn't want my daughter
to grow up in a in a split home
with like having to choose like
a new parent and a new family so
you went back to my husband so you
weren't scared of a new relationship you
were scared of your daughter
growing up in a in a separate house okay
that makes sense
and so why'd you get divorced a second
time to the same guy
for the same reasons we just aren't
compatible we just don't get along we
don't have the same life goals
give me some more details than just not
compatible and there's a reason why i'm
asking this um but
not just to be gratuitous yeah well
he doesn't have the same work ethic as
me drive
we don't agree on parenting his parents
pretty much hand him everything and
don't really make him work hard for
anything and
my mom is completely the opposite of
that we've always had to work really
hard for everything in our life
so those things sound like those things
sound like some things that
every couple goes through something
below that
made you get divorced twice what is it
those are just discomforts those are
things that every couple deals with i
thought we should do this i should do
this
those are usually navigational issues
something below that made you get
divorced twice
we got married because i got pregnant
okay my daughter
so i married him because i thought it
was the right thing to do for her
ah there we go and did you did you
resent him
um no
i i didn't at the time i think i did
more now i just kind of felt like i was
doing the right thing
like god picked him for me because i was
so bad at picking people before and then
that happened and i was like well
this is the one and thought that i could
learn to love him
and i i guess that's kind of where i'm
like
getting into the dating scene i don't
want to just learn to love somebody but
i also know the
butterflies and the fireworks that's not
always healthy either
right right right so here's a couple of
things i could pass on to you
learn to i'm making a note here so
i think first i want to differentiate
between learn to
and choose to learn to
suggest that something is going to come
from out there and present itself to you
as like new knowledge or new information
or
new things you can brush under the rug
like he's just gross and or he's rude or
he
yells at our kids instead of hugs
whatever the things are and you're going
to learn to deal with those things
and that's not a healthy way to approach
relationships you can learn new
information
to process it and you use the
information but just
learning to that's not a good way to
look at it i do believe
with all of my heart this idea of
choosing
you do choose to be in love
you do choose to be in a relationship
you do choose to remain married
there's a great theologian rich mullins
who once said the worst part about being
a christian is that it's every single
day
and you can never memorize enough
scripture that you don't got to get up
and try to live right the next day
that same thing applies to exercise
right you can never have such a good
workout on a monday that you're squared
up for the rest of the month the worst
part about being in shape is you got to
get up on tuesday and work out again
and get up on on wednesday and either
rest or
fix your body and work out again love is
the same way
and i heard this maybe a few months ago
and it stuck in my soul
where do you think we get our most
um detailed metaphor for love the
the picture we get of romance and of
love and of
starstruck love and i just gave you a
hint there where does that come from
where's our picture of
ultimate love come from
i have no idea all right here's where it
comes from romeo and juliet
okay romeo and juliet two star struck
lovers who see each other from across
the room at a party
the gods faded them together and then
they end up dying because their love is
so is so deep
or maybe titanic right or the notebook
or any of these things where you see
somebody it's
it and then you are willing to die and
the reality is this
like romeo and juliet were two teenagers
who wanted to hook up
they secretly got married and they threw
a temper tantrum and one killed the
other one and then killed himself
and so these two 16 year olds have
become our model
right or jack and rose on a boat
um and i forgot rachel mcadams and
gosling i forgot their their
character names um kelly through the
booth has given me a hard time here
noah and ally she couldn't let it be
noah and ally right
here's the thing love in relationship in
marriage is a choice
and so what you are going to have to do
when you head back out there chelsea is
you're going to have to decide
i want to love this person and if you
get the butterflies and the feelings and
the things that's great
or you're going to choose not to love
that person right so that's number one
number two you're gonna find out about
yourself
and childhood insecurities all of these
do i look good am i first in line does
he like me
does he listen to me do i have acne all
these things that you thought you did
away with in middle school will come
flooding back to you and so most people
get caught off guard honestly most many
people get caught off guard
by this re-emergence of this little girl
or these little boy insecurities that
come rushing out after having been in a
long-term relationship
and you'll get this sense like man i
thought i would be past this by now i
thought i'd be all growed up and
everything be all good
the reality is no those things live deep
in you because they're only healed
through relationship
and now you're dealing with a fractured
relationship and the final thing i'll
tell you is this
expect to have doubts about your
judgment
or another way i could say it is you're
going to lose trust in yourself
because you thought that god told you to
do something when you got pregnant and
so you got married
and then you chose to get divorced
and you thought that was the right thing
and then you got remarried
and then you got divorced again so most
people forget
when they get divorced they're not just
losing a partner they're not losing a
dream they're not losing a
future they're also dealing with lost
trust in themselves
and so what i want to recommend is you
go out as you start hitting the dating
scene
obviously you're going to respect your
kids right you're not going to bring
home knuckleheads to meet your kids
until you are very very serious you're
not going to drag them through a series
of relationships so that goes without
saying
but i want you to have somebody that you
can talk to whether it's a close friend
and not just like a yeah girl not a
friend like that but somebody who's a
little bit older a little bit wiser
maybe
somebody's been remarried maybe a
counselor maybe somebody at your local
church somebody who
will walk with you and will give you
some insight and some wisdom to deal
with the
exciting butterfly moments the the
middle school high school moments
and then the middle school high school
college and securities
and the ups and the downs and then as
you choose
not as you feel fated or as you feel
oh it's going to happen but as you
choose to say
this is the guy that i want to spend the
rest of my life with this is the guy
that i'm going to get up every day and
decide
that i'm going to love this is the guy
that i'm going to
lean in towards even when he's annoying
even when he's frustrating even when i
feel vulnerable
that's going to be the guy that you end
up with that's going to be the guy
that's going to help you have a healthy
marriage
and i'm going to expect him to do the
same thing for you i'm going to expect
him to choose you
every day and choosing is so
so hard so prepare to feel insecure
again prepare to feel like you don't
trust your instincts anymore
prepare to have somebody that walks with
you a community of people
that you trust go for it man go for it
chelsea
protect your kids in this process and
protect your heart so thank you so much
for the call
let's go to one more call let's go to
one more we got time for julia
in salt lake city julia
what's up i feel singing this morning
man what is up julia
hi dr d um so i have a question
in regards to my marriage and my
husband's video game playing
um he plays hold on hold on did you just
say my husband's video game play
yes oh my gosh james and kelly
so far today we have had the downloading
operating system into kids
we've had parents who don't take their
kids to funerals
and the trifecta you're telling me you
got a husband who plays video games i
got to hear more about this go for it
yeah so um it gets excessive i mean it's
always excessive
but i there are like two versions of him
there's a version that can like balance
that with normal life
and then there's a version of him that
ignores everything else and can't deal
with real life
can't hold a conversation doesn't want
to go to family events doesn't want to
talk to his mom
doesn't want to play with our daughter
like it's so
bad and he's had this problem since
early childhood um i didn't know how bad
it was until after we were married
um so this has been going for like 25
years
at this point um because his mom just
couldn't ever like pull the plug on it
when he was a kid
and why did she not do that
she she tried single mom tried to do her
best
she thought just changing the password
on the computer was enough but he got
his own computers
and he'd play all day and through the
night and
okay can i stop you right there because
i want to i want to say this publicly
this is not to you this is to everybody
out listening
a parent who comes to me and says hey my
nine-year-old is addicted to their ipad
i'll always stop them and say that's
bullcrap
nine-year-olds only get ipads through
their parents
period end of story in the discussion
my kid won't stop playing video games
then you take the controllers and you
smash them into a million pieces
kids only have access to this nonsense
when their parents
are either too insecure or i'll give it
to you they're exhausted i
i understand that and a single mom
trying to navigate
their day and two jobs in school i
understand handing a kid a controller
because it just keeps everybody happy i
get that i get it i get it
but i this i just couldn't pull the plug
that's
that's it's parents not owning up to
their responsibilities and stepping in
that gap
and getting rid of the freaking
controllers all right that's that's my
aside
go go back julia yes you're good
um so when i met him while we were
dating
he was hardly playing at all as far as i
could tell um he was really involved in
church he
was really thoughtful about dating we
had like a really good
social circle and we were just like
always out and about doing stuff he took
good care of himself
and then after being married for a
little bit we've been married for four
years now
um like every six months or so i just
have to have like a complete breakdown
to snap him out of it because he's just
lost in his video game world
and what does the lost mean like how
many hours a day
like at an absolute minimum three to
four hours
typically after a work day seven to
eight hours and then on weekends
probably like double that at least wow
so this is a full-blown lifelong
addiction
yeah like he gets home from work and i'm
like hey i need you to take care of the
baby and he's like okay give me a minute
and he goes and logs in on his computer
and i'm like
wow so are these the the multi uh
a multi online player games does he have
a whole community that he's going to
like trolls and frogs and navy snipers
that he's running around with
yeah it's it's so it's really strange
sometimes he's like oh yeah
it's all about the community it's
because you know like i need like my
boys he doesn't know any of these people
in person
and he never will right um because
they're not real and other times
yeah or they're middle schoolers in
russia
yeah other times though he's just
mindlessly clicking and it's the same
game he's played since he was a kid
and i i actually like banned it for a
while i was like i'm done
i like this has to go away and he
humored me for like three or four months
and then
one day he was like yeah so i downloaded
it on my phone
and i've been playing during my lunch
breaks and so i don't think it's that
much of a problem and he put it back on
his computer again and
so what he's playing now what is your
sex life like
what is your intimate life like it's
it's kind of gone away some of that has
to do with our baby being born this year
and just sleep deprivation and c-section
recovery
and ptsd and a number of things um
so back me up right before the baby was
born still four to six hours
i mean i'm just looking at the math on
the hours here right i mean there's not
a lot of time to squeeze in connection
time
no no there's not and i told him that
too he's like
like every once in a while he'll say oh
like you know like
our intimate life has disappeared i'm
like yeah because like i'm not a
microwave you can't just push a button
and i'm ready to go like you have to
actually pay attention to me we have to
do date night we have to cuddle
sometimes without the expectation that
that's going to happen
it takes effort on your part and so
sometimes he puts in that effort and
other times he's like i
like it's too much i'm just going to
play my games because that's easy
wow so we'll talk about the video game
thing here in a minute
i don't want you to blow by the sense of
rejection
in the sense of um
i wish i had a better word for it i'm
kind of at a loss right now i
the infidelity that he's choosing video
games he's choosing
yeah rolling around with middle school
kids um
with his controllers as opposed to
being with his wife and i don't want you
to miss that
and i know that's easy to focus on the
video game part but that's got to suck
right that hurts yeah yeah that hurts
definitely
um so i don't want to to minimize this
there are guys who come home and numb
out
who don't either don't have the tools
and and women do it too right there's
men and women who don't have the tools
to be in relationships they don't have
the tools you said you got a young kid
right they don't have the tools for
dealing with the stress and the
overwhelming feelings of
shame and what do i do when a newborn
comes home they don't know how to deal
with rejection at work
that happens right and there's folks who
spend one or two or three hours a night
four to six hours a night eight to nine
hours a night
has so many derivative bad effects
from lack of sleep to lack of human
contact
to literally living in a fantasy
that's his every bit as far as i'm
concerned as dangerous
as an alcoholic addict as someone who's
cheating on their wife
because they are choosing other
behaviors or choosing other
fake relationships to numb out and not
have to deal with the person in front of
them
and so now that you've got a daughter
here
i want you to be very serious about
thinking through
protecting your daughter and his
daughter
from this level of disconnection because
she will
quickly understand that she is in second
place to a computer
that she is in second place to a distant
father
more insidiously it'll be a distant
person who's in the same house
right and a kid can not not regulate
well but they understand the physical
presence dad isn't here
right dad left us dad moved out mom
moved away she's got a new husband
but when they're in the same room and
they're distant from you
kids will backfill that with this is my
fault this gap is my fault
and they will try all sorts of
connecting numbing behaviors to try to
bridge that gap
and this is a serious thing um i
again just in my own house just for what
it's worth
there are no video game consoles my kid
wouldn't know how to turn a video game
on
now i'm i'm crazy about it right so i
know there's gonna be a million people
you think the crossfit community came
after me man the the video game folks
i get it right um but i want my kid to
experience
outside i want my kid to experience
playing baseball with dad just throwing
it back and forth i had to learn i'm
still having to learn
how to play dolls with my daughter how
to just be
bored and be connected with my kids and
what they think is interesting we're
going to think is interesting or
if i'm out doing yard work my kids are
coming with me if i'm going hunting or
fishing my kids are going with me
and that's part of the responsibility of
having kids
now i don't want to say all video games
are evil or whatever that's just the
stance i've taken
mainly because i can't control myself i
don't mind saying this again on this
podcast a few years ago
before i knew they were a bunch of
cheaters i was a a
near religious astros fan and one of the
things i gave myself
for a gift was the mlb ticket
and so i ordered i got all the astros
games just piped into my house
and i found myself cutting home from
work and i would just go lay on the
couch i was exhausted i was on call 24 7
365 i was just working working working
and i'd just go lay down
and my son came in one day and he asked
me a question that was a dagger to my
soul
and i really haven't picked up
professional sports or college sports
since
because i'd get home and i'd say hey son
why don't you come lay down and watch
the game with me we love the astros
together
and he'd say well let's just go play
catch and i'd be like let's watch these
guys they're professionals
and that was my way of numbing out i was
exhausted i didn't want to go chase a
ball he was like six or seven and he
threw the ball crazy all over the place
and then one day he came in and asked me
this question hey daddy
and it wasn't a drama question it wasn't
a
um a guilt question he was just like a
seven-year-old or eight-year-old
asking for facts asking for data hey dad
do you love me as much as the astros i
was like
say what do you love me as much as the
astros
because i was laying on the couch
watching them and he was just standing
there
and i looked at him and said son i love
you more than i will ever ever love the
astros and i got up and turned off the
game
and i really haven't gone back i really
haven't gone back
because my son is more important my wife
is more important my daughter is more
important my community is more important
than living in a fantasy world then
living in
a fake world of elves and trolls
and shooter games and all the things
while the world is spinning and passing
us by
so for you julia i you've got to
intervene you've got to intervene in a
significant way
and so i'm going to recommend you go
meet with a professional counselor
to get some tools on how to identify
your personal values the values you're
going to have in your home for raising
your daughter and of course you're doing
this with him
and i you're gonna have to come up with
some or what behaviors
some or what ideas because at this point
this is a lifelong thing he is connected
to this box your husband is
he's connected to this game this this
pseudo fantasy community
and he's not going to be able to turn it
off on his own and
you're not going to be able to have blow
ups you're not going to be able to
punish him into recovery he's going to
have to decide
i want human interaction i want to learn
how to be uncomfortable with other
people
i'm going to have to learn how to be
disappointed and feel ashamed
and feel nervous and feel
sexy and feel loved he's gonna have to
learn how to do all those feelings
because
his mom didn't teach him his mom didn't
teach him
and it is what it is that's the husband
you've got right now
i hope beyond hope beyond hope he will
lean in and say you are right my wife my
daughter my family my future is more
important
than an imaginary game i hope you will i
hope you will i hope you will
the tools are out there and the
resources are out there but at this
point julia all you can do is you can
take care of you
your thoughts and your actions and
you've got to protect that daughter of
hers
and so go see somebody asap start
working through this process
and then be ready to have a good deep
clarifying boundary filled conversation
with your husband
and one last piece of advice don't have
that conversation one night at midnight
when you're just frustrated and you're
angry
set it up put it on the calendar make it
a destination y'all go to breakfast have
somebody come
take your daughter for vacation and
y'all go have this conversation in a
controlled quiet setting
and just say enough is enough i'm not
going to share my life and my daughter
with a video game
period i hope i hope he turns around and
i hope he realizes how important you and
your daughter are
call me back in a few weeks after you
have this conversation after you've had
time to meet with a professional i want
to hear how this is going
and if he wants to call me i'd love to
talk to him too have him give me a call
or shoot me an email at ask john ramsey
solutions.com that'd be fantastic
all right so as we wrap up today's show
man we had some heavy ones today
it really kind of comes back to just
being intentional with your kids loving
your kids
recognizing that they are important that
the person you chose to marry as
important
they just are and you choose you choose
you choose you choose
love your kids love your spouses love
yourself
alright so as we wrap up we're going to
go to the song lyric of the day i know
i've talked about some some fancy songs
but this one spoke to my heart back in
1997 i was in college
whoo we had u2 was out the beatles of
course were doing their thing we had
some extraordinary hip-hop
artists but then out of nowhere three
brothers hit the scene
and just like like a like a parachute of
love and joy
that dropped down in my heart the 1997
legendary classic record middle of
nowhere
by the one and only hanson they gave us
listen to the poetry here you have so
many relationships in this life
only one or two will last you will go
through all the pain and strife
then you turn your back and they're gone
so fast oh yeah
and they're gone so fast comma yeah
so hold on to the ones who really care
in the end they'll be the only ones
there
when you get old and start losing your
hair can you tell me who still will care
can you tell me who still will care oh
yeah
get this
do bop yeah yeah this
is the dr john dolone show